I remember day come on down to the car
and see people look at me like I was
crazy like a crispy carrot it's
technically possible if anyone to do it
it don't matter in the belief that you
all have a god that's just profound it
was so enticing because it was so much
wish fulfillment job you asked the fly
and it was that moment where we realized
a secured didn't need to be restricted
in any way we will allow these
outrageous moment and flying through the
air and building the building was
playing to that it was one of those
answers to the riddles how do we one-up
spectacle of each show traditionally we
always tried to take a practical
approach first the first one we went to
place car driving school as we continued
making a film it was more important for
us to go to stunt driving school so
we'll take a practical run but something
that registers that if you want to know
if Paul night drove someone going to the
next as much as I'd like to say may be
pretty obvious might not have been
distracting what's funny is if you talk
to us back then we'd be willing to do
anything without taking away the magic
of moviemaking
thank God that that was in 2014 and we
were able to use CGI the way we did and
you can learn as much as you want when
it's actually shoot day and the
pyrotechnics of launching fireballs in
there and you're driving through smoke
it's always a dangerous thing I don't
think the world realized how much this
one have to consider when doing
something because this one car
fortunately we were safe it's been so
many greats done I'd say this is in the
top spot my first reaction was giddy I
was like holy [ __ ] we pulled it off
right away
when you're sitting in that beater and
you see that pin the first thing that
reacts
hold it as a testament to an iconic
monks after the first month Paul Walker
and I were at the airport and were just
sitting on the floor people were walking
on for us and he looked over to me take
all this and because this will be our
last moment of anonymity
he knew that we sux accorded public
somehow it's a big part of my life of
the happy time and severe another
college that has comes like this also a
child but I'm proud and every moment and
every frame everybody has contributed to
this record-breaking zhonya
[Music]